the people are desperate for justice
Chris Pine is stripping down the stigma
surrounding male full frontal nudity in
film let's just get straight to the 38
year old actor stopped by the Graham
Norton Show where he opened up about the
press he's received for going totally
nude in his upcoming flick outlaw King
Wow 50 men defied the strongest quote I
bear the full monty and it got a lot of
attention
I thought the witty reviews were
brilliant but what did strike me most is
that Florence Pugh bears everything -
and no one commented in the movie pew
plays Elizabeth the wife of pines enemy
14th century Scottish rebel Robert pine
added that he doesn't think it's fair
that her nudity and his nudity aren't
talked about the same way I am not sure
what that means either people think they
can't comment or everyone expects women
to get naked
either way it's double standards et sat
down with pine recently to talk about
his new movie and he dished on the
attention his on-screen nudity has
received
people are saying that you're full monty
is the breakout star of tiff what you
think man pretty cool right pretty cool
I'll take it but this isn't the first
time pine has spoken out about the
double standards for women in Hollywood
would you say you're a typical example
of your sex I am above average
in 2017 he told ET he was quote
objectified for his role in Wonder Woman
in which he showed off his backside on
the big screen can we talk about the
Amazon pools it was fun to be
objectified for a day it's like my I was
thinking I got women it's happened to
women so so so much it's you know it's
about time
[Music]
[Applause]